and I've stalling the Hennig is
polynomial operations and in numbers we
know what operations are right
operations are things which can put
numbers together you get a new number at
the end polynomial operations are just
the same except instead of the building
block being numbers we're now dealing
with entire polynomials and getting them
to interact with each other okay now
just like with numbers there are four
key operations that we can do with
polynomials I'll start you off we can
add them so what does addition of these
polynomials look like well if you say P
of X plus Q of X then we can simply get
a term by term we can collect like terms
because you notice there's a couple here
that I can deal with and you get a new
polynomial polynomial at the other end
so for example you can see that there
are only x squared terms in P right so
I'm just going to write the x squared
term there there are X terms in both P
and Q so when you collect like terms
what do you get minus minus 2x good and
then when you look at the constant terms
plus one minus four looks like we're
gonna end up with minus three okay so
I've added these two polynomials it
might be dramas just like adding I can
do subtraction because these are inverse
operations so instead of doing one plus
the other I'm going to do one takeaway
no big dramas here so again I'm going to
look at this time oughta matters so I'm
gonna have to do the top one takeaway
the bottom one x squared it doesn't get
subtracted there are no other collecting
light tones that happen here minus three
X minus X how many X's do I end up with
minus four and then when I have a look
at the constant term it's one takeaway
negative four which leaves me with plus
five okay before we move on to the other
operations I want you to notice some
things at the degrees here right
polynomials P and Q you can tell me what
their degrees are pretty quickly right
the degree of P is so
the degree of Q is one and now I want
you to look at the degrees of the sums
and differences right P plus Q what's
its degree two and P minus Q its degree
also two so when you add that was just I
was bordering on it evacuation like
there anyway
when you add polynomials so you can see
you end up with the degree that was
highest out of your original functions
does that make sense or polynomials I
should say okay so no big deal but it
starts to get a little more complicated
when we look at more interesting
operations so if I instead don't add or
subtract but multiply these two if I say
P of x times Q of X I want you to make a
prediction what's going to happen to the
degree well you've got degree 2 times
degree 1 and these are just some well
you're just going to do something a lot
of stuff right so when you've got stuff
which is a power of two and you multiply
it by stuff which has a power of 1 what
do you end up with you get a power of 3
so the degree that I'm going to get here
if you put together a quadratic in a
linear function you'll end up with a
cubic of some kind and we could work out
what this is it wouldn't take too long
I'm gonna multiply everything by X that
gives me this like so and then I'm gonna
multiply everything by negative 4 so
that gives me let's see here
well that's a plus did that look right
did I expand Garrett my brackets okay
you can see why I've written it in two
lines like this can you see why it just
helps me identify all of my life terms
so there's X cubed how many x squared x
minus seven how many X's 13 and then
that constant term is just hanging out
there on the end okay so as we predicted
because we know our index laws the
degree of our product of these two
polynomials is the sum of the degrees of
the two polynomials started with if I
had a quadratic in a cubic you'd expect
this thing down here to have a degree of
5 that would be a quintic okay not that
they come up very often okay addition
subtraction multiplication I've left the
last one because it's the harness and
it's actually we're going to devote some
energy into division okay now the tricky
thing with this is if you add two
polynomials
you'll get another polynomial if you
subtract two polynomials from cannot
upon it if you multiply two polynomials
you get the idea but if you divide three
polynomials you may not get a polynomial
okay don't write this down and I just
wanted to give it to you as a point of
illustration if I gave you an easy one
like say this khouzam you guys know my
fondness for this particular polynomial
if I looked at that numerator is a
particular polynomial and this numerator
as a this denominator as a particular
polymer you can see here that the answer
would be another polynomial what would
it be the X plus 3 it's worth noting
that these two things are not identical
right because there's a domain
restriction on this that doesn't exist
over here but it's still fine noting
that domain restriction there's nothing
wrong with polynomials having domain
restrictions you get another polynomial
at the end but if you have a look at the
P and Q that I have given you you can
see that this is not gonna fall out nice
and neatly is it in fact I'm giving you
one up here which you pretty much can
you even factorize that B Square boos
yeah you can you can
you don't have to get a certain aren't
you okay but X minus four is not going
to be one of those factors so what am I
going to do with this okay I want you to
make a separate side subheading because
this is such a big deal which is long
division